للوقوف على الوضع الميداني في هذه الساعه
تنضم الينا من غزه مراسله الجزيره هبه
عكيله اهلا بك هبه نتابع معك اخر التطورات
نعم تواصل القصف الاسرائيلي على مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه معظم هذا القصف كان
قصف مدفعي استهدف مناطق حدوديه في بيت
حانون وفي عزبه عبد ربه شمال قطاع غزه
وايضا في خان يونس وفي رفح في المنطقه
الوسطى وفي جنوب مدينه غزه هذا القصف
المدفعي ايضا تزامن مع قصف من طائره مسيره
استهدفت منزلا يعود لعائله الكفارنه
بصاروخ يطلق عليه هنا صاروخ تحذيري هو
صاروخ من طائره مسيره يستهدف هذا المنزل
يصيب بعض الاضرار ولكن القصد من هذا
الصاروخ يكون في العاده هو تحذير لسكان
هذا المنزل باخلاء المنزل
وبالتالي يقوم سكان المنزل بالمغادره
وكذلك يغادر عدد من المنازل القريبه من
هذا المنزل منازلهم هذا ما حدث تماما في
الليله الماضيه عندما قامت طائرات مسيره
باطلاق صواريخ تحذيريه على منزل في بيت
لاهيا يعود لعائله المصري ومنزل اخر يعود
لعائله الاغا في خان يونس وكذلك تم قصف
هذه المنازل بعد وقت محدود من اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ من المسيرات من قبل طائرات حربيه
اسرائيليه استهدفت هذه المنازل هذه
المنازل مكونه من ثلاثه طوابق تم تدميرها
بالكامل وتسويتها بالارض اذن اربعه منازل
الان منذ الليله الماضيه وحتى الان
ضمن ثلاثه منازل دمرت بالكامل والمنزل
الرابع اطلق عليه حتى الان صاروخين من
طائره طائرات استطلاع اسرائيليه
اضافه لعدد كبير ايضا من الشقق السكنيه
بدات اسرائيل هذه هذا التصعيد وهذه
العمليه العسكريه ضد قطاع غزه كانت
البدايه مع اغتيال ثلاثه من ابرز قاده
سرايا القدس باستهدافهم داخل منازلهم
وبالتالي ادى الى استشهاد في اول
غاراتها المتزامنه على ثلاثه منازل الى
استشهاد 13 فلسطينيه منهم القاده الثلاثه
وافراد من اسرهم زوجاتهم وبعض ابنائهم
وكانت الحصيله عدد كبير من المدنيين اضافه
الى استشهاد القيادات هذه الليله اعادت
اسرائيل سياسه الاغتيال باغتيال علي غالي
وهو مسؤول الوحده الصاروخيه في سرايا
القدس واستشهد معه اثنان اخرون وبالتالي
ارتفع عدد الشهداء الى 25 شهيدا وعدد
الاصابات الى 76 اصابه
منهم اصابات خطيره واصابات حرجه ويجب
التنويه هنا بان معظم الاصابات هي لمدنيين
والعدد الاكبر للاطفال ونساء استمرار هذا
القصف الاسرائيلي على هذه المناطق السكنيه
وحتى عندما تتحدث اسرائيل عن استهداف انض
فارغه او عن مرصد او حتى عن منصات لاطلاق
الصواريخ هي بالفعل مناطق مقتظه بالسكان
عندما نتحدث عن ارض فارغه فنحن نعلم ان
مساحه قطاع غزه مساحه محدوده جدا وهو
الاكثر كثافه في العالم بالنسبه لعدد
السكان وبالتالي المنازل قريبه جدا
الاماكن السكنيه قريبه من هذه
من هذه المناطق التي تستهدف من قبل
المدفعيه ومن قبل الطيران الاسرائيلي